la comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos constató que la respuesta del
estado colombiano a las protestas
sociales que comenzaron el pasado 28 de
abril se caracterizó por el uso excesivo
y desproporcionado de la fuerza y que en
muchos casos la situación incluyó la
fuerza letal para hablar sobre este tema
quiero saludar en este momento a antonia
urréjola comisionada presidenta de la
sej de alce bienvenida a france 24
las ideas que presentó el informe sobre
la visita que hizo en junio pasado en
colombia para revisar numerosas
denuncias de violencia policial y civil
que dejó decenas de muertos y miles de
heridos durante las manifestaciones
ustedes le hicieron 40 recomendaciones
al estado colombiano cuáles son las que
más resaltan
bueno yo diría que en primer lugar la
necesidad de la rendición de cuentas por
parte de los miembros de la de las
fuerzas de seguridad respecto de las
violaciones a los derechos humanos que
están establecidas en el informe
otro tema me parece muy importante es la
creación de una comisión para la para la
búsqueda de los desaparecidos hay mucha
información y denuncia sobre personas
desaparecidas
la defensoría de personas no localizadas
a reducir 60 si tanto si se habla de 84
personas desaparecidas más allá de
personas no localizadas o personas
desaparecidas es un número muy alto y
por otra parte también hay un conjunto
de recomendaciones también los días a
las fuerzas de seguridad pero sobre todo
es muy especialmente un llamado que
hacemos con mucha mucha vehemencia diría
yo el llamado al diálogo el que vamos al
diálogo amplio e inclusivo no solo a
nivel nacional sino que también a nivel
local y territorial nos preocupa mucho
durante la visita el nivel de
estigmatización el discurso del enemigo
de los bandos enemigos una mirada que
todavía claramente está insertada en el
conflicto armado en colombia y nuestro
llamado es que las distintas autoridades
políticas tanto del gobierno como
legislativo y actores sociales cierto
usen un lenguaje que no se estigmatice y
sino que un lenguaje que el que logre
cierto un diálogo real creemos que ese
es el mayor desafío que tiene hoy día
colombia
antonia cuál es su reacción después de
que el gobierno de iván duque rechazara
mayoritariamente los hallazgos de este
informe puede hacer algo la cdh para que
el gobierno acate las recomendaciones
bueno en primer lugar las
recomendaciones se enmarcan cierto
dentro de lo que es una de las
facultades de la comisión la comisión
tiene varias facultades una de esas las
facultades de monitoreo y para eso para
sus monitoreos la comisión tiene
facultades de realizar visitas de
trabajo como la que hicimos en colombia
a partir de esas visitas la comisión las
en conjunto recomendaciones y esas
recomendaciones son establecía en virtud
de los estándares interamericanos y los
tratados internacionales en este caso
que ha ratificado colombia por lo tanto
nosotros insistimos que esas
recomendaciones son obligatorias desde
la perspectiva la buena fe dado que
colombia es parte del sistema
interamericano porque en virtud su
propia soberanía independencia se ha
sometido es cierto al sistema
interamericano tanto la comisión como la
corte y ha ratificado un conjunto de
tratados internacionales y el principio
de buena fe indica cierto que si uno se
suscribe a un un órgano de derecho
un conjunto de tratados internacionales
en principio con efe es que uno debe
cumplir lo dicho lo anterior
nosotros tenemos una relación permanente
de algo con el estado colombiano y eso
tengo que recalcar lo más
las declaraciones públicas que hemos
escuchado en estos días nosotros
permanentemente tenemos intercambio
información tenemos reuniones con el
estado colombiano y yo espero que esto
no sea la acepción y vamos a continuar
dialogando con un estado que
institucionalidad democrática que tiene
aspectos que debe mejorar y por eso un
conjunto de recomendaciones pero estamos
ante un estado cierto que tiene una
institucionalidad que estoy segura que
va a ayudar al cumplimiento de aquellas
recomendaciones a través de un diálogo
que a veces volver con todos los estados
no eso no es algo que nosotros nos
llamen la atención
antonia muy rápidamente pudieron ustedes
constatar la infiltración de grupos
vandálicos para deslegitimar las
protestas como lo denuncia el gobierno
del presidente iván duque si
efectivamente no sólo el propio estado y
otros órganos
independientes del estado sino también
esto es muy importante las
organizaciones de humanos nos hicieron
la misma denuncia es decir esa
preocupación de que las manifestaciones
siendo infiltradas por grupos armados
ilegales por manifestantes que lo que
quieren es hacer vandalismo
delictuales eres denuncias que recibimos
de alguna manera que pagaste
organizaciones de tu mano y también de
parte del estado y ahí hago urgente es
la necesidad de investigar esos actos
vandálicos determinar quién es antonio y
que se sometía bueno lamentablemente se
nos acabó el tiempo antonia como
presidenta comisionada de la cdh muchas
gracias por acompañarnos en cinco
minutos con ustedes muchas gracias por
sintonizarnos quédense con nosotros
[Música]